[Music]
in our morning rounds changing the light
bulbs in your house could help you sleep
better more than a third of Americans
say they don't get the recommended seven
hours of sleep a night a new study says
replacing regular light bulbs with a
special bulb that emits less blue light
could get you to fall asleep faster we
have both types of light bulbs under
lampshades as you can see here in the
studio on the left is a lamp with a
normal fluorescent bulb looks a little
blue on the right you can see the
special LED night bulb
Michael Bruce is a clinical psychologist
and specialist in sleep medicine good
morning good morning thanks for having
me so blue is bad for sleep blue is bad
for sleep so it turns out that there's a
very particular wavelength of light
that's blue and it would hit certain
cells in your I called melanopsin cells
it tells them to turn off the melatonin
faucet in your brain well you kind of
want that faucet on when you're trying
to fall asleep at night and now there's
technology that we can all have in our
homes that can allow us to do that so
this is just your average light bulb
it's not and here it is this is the one
this is another one yeah and it's pretty
interesting so I actually have these in
my home in my bedside table lamps and I
also have them in my kids rooms because
I don't want my kids having light
exposure at night and then they also
make a bulb that's the opposite of this
it's called the good day bulb and my son
has no idea but I have those in his
bathroom so in the morning when he gets
in there it's like the Sun comes in it
is like something here
why do you have the light on when you're
trying to sleep so it's before bed so if
you're reading or whatever you're doing
right before bed you wouldn't have it on
during sleep yeah what do you call that
this one is called the good night light
bulb I think it runs about 25 dollars
it's available I think on Amazon your
various websites things like that and in
my studies I found other things besides
light bulbs that can help with this blue
light exposure at night so there's a
computer program that you can download
for free called flux and you put in the
times that you want it to and it'll
automatically change the light that's
being emitted there there are apps so if
you look on your for example I have an
iPhone there's something called
nightshift that you can turn on that
will lower that I even recently
discovered a supplement that you can
ingest called blue teen and it actually
increased
is the natural blue light filters in the
eye so there's some amazing technology
going on out there one of the things
that I think people struggle with is
getting up in the middle of the night
and having to turn on a light but I've
always used a red light bulb because
they say that that's there you go this
working the same one this would work in
the red light but tell him why yeah so
because again this blue light there was
a new study that came out this week that
talked about this is from researchers
doctors Raman Hillary and Lockley out of
Harvard and what they discovered was
when they compared fluorescent bulbs to
the technology that's in this bulb not
only did people have higher melatonin
with this bulb but better alertness the
next day which is really the key factor
for many people out there yeah it
doesn't wake you up right exactly so
it's pretty it's pretty interesting
stuff we really need to start thinking
about light as medicine so bright light
affects all aspects of our health it
affects us in lots of different ways you
know just like there's junk food I think
there's junk light thank you Michael
thank you thank you very much